you know the crowd just went wild when
you came over obi-wan kenobi you know so
exciting hayden christian center you are
up there you said it you know the
reaction to the prequels wasn't always
the best but it changed over the past
couple of years and now you guys are
like rock stars up there the fans are so
excited what is it like getting that
warm welcome it feels really good i've
never been to a star wars convention
i've never been to celebration before so
for me it's a new experience and it was
really nice to do that but it is true
what i said
over the last
some years i don't know exactly how long
five years six years i've definitely met
more and more people who were kids when
the films came out that we made and and
for them
our star wars films are their star wars
films you know in the same way that alec
guinness and carrie fisher's one was for
me so
i'm i'm really touched by that it really
has made me because i think i think they
were
they were sort of like
[Music]
the reaction to them there was no social
media we didn't hear what the audience
felt
we just heard from the critics and they
had decided that it didn't make them
feel like the original three had made
them feel so they sort of trounced on
them
and that was really hard to i was young
and i was
i'd thrown myself into this massive
can you imagine like getting up getting
up to play obi-wan kenobi the young alec
guinness as a young actor was just
amazing and for them to people to sort
of poo poo it would it sort of put i
think i put my blinkers up to star wars
really and
um and i it's a shame i feel like
i did play i did play him in the
prequels you know what i mean and i i
feel like now i want to own it more and
and this is this is cool it just felt
great to feel that support from
everybody out there it felt good yeah
you know you and hayden both obviously
went through that experience together
with the prequels but now you're both
together for this the excitement how
would you describe your relationship
with him and what it was like being on
set with him like did you pick right
back up where he left off
it was very strange like looking over
the set at him
and it was just like the last 17 years
didn't happen you know
i mean you'll see you'll see what it
feels like in the show and um but you
know i love hayden and i i we spent a
very special time together then he was
just 18 19 years old it was his first
job i think really maybe not his first
job but he was very very new to it and
stepping into these
big boots to fill playing anakin
skywalker playing the young
darth vader was pretty epic and to be
around him was great you know
and we spent we shot those first two
films in australia and sydney and and uh
we just had a lot of time together
because we had all these fights to learn
we worked out together we were on set
together and then we you know we were
out after after work we would go out
together as well and it was just great
we we we missed each other and it's nice
to be back well you both don't ever seem
to age so it's really nice for you guys
you